if you had a psychic bomb inside of your
head what would you do you must learn to
control your powers but each time you
use them you will be one step closer to
death no one can help you and you'll
have to battle horrifying Killers using
kids as meat Shields fing off psycho
Cults and getting into death games with
the most powerful psychics of all time
while going through the most terrifying
thing of all time eighth grade I'm going
to break down the mistakes made what you
should do and how to beat ghost puberty
and MOB psycho 100 this guy student is
about to kill everyone he knows Reagan
here is your local fake psychic that
pretends to solve real ghost problems
using pure confidence getting called on
his next case this scared couple pays
him to perform an exorcism and a ghost
shows up but they figure out this guy is
a fraud and everyone is about to die but
Reagan plays it cool and calls up his
Ultimate Weapon this confused kid named
mob who's running out of time 22% until
mob explosion seeking his master's
approval mob instantly obliterates this
ghost like it was nothing and completes
the case shocking everyone here but
after he tells his boss that he feels
weird each time he uses his powers and
thinks something bad will soon happen if
he keeps doing this but rean tells him
what's at stake the only way to control
his powers is by figuring out his mind
and practicing or else his powers will
soon kill him anyways so keep it on keep
it on Mob quickly realizes that he must
figure his [__] out and discover who he
really is before his mind kills him and
he rushes back home to his family to
calm himself after a stressful day and
chills with his more awesome brother
Ritu born without powers rzu has to rely
on just his brains and MOB wishes he was
more successful in life like and not a
monster but his jealous brother will
soon try to kill him the next day at
school he messes up talking to his high
school Crush again and starts to think
that without girls liking him he'll
never be happy in life and starts to
stress out more 25% until mob explosion
he heads on over to meet his boss
getting warned that his next assignment
is risky as hell the job sneak into this
school to meet a client dressed up as
school girls reaching they suddenly
don't let Reagan in forcing mob to go in
without him now alone without his master
he struggles to calm down before he
faces his next death match match alone
35% until mob explosion sneaking in he
meets the client these girls telling him
his boss can't make it and pisses off
these two they don't think mob can
handle what's at stake the girl thinks
this ghost is nothing like he's ever
seen but he soon senses the Target and
traps it in the stadium announcing his
presence and putting the evil ghost on
alert okay while it looks like we're in
serious trouble there was a much better
way easier way to do this all right okay
it involves chemically reacting rocks
and stealing a crap ton of money from
school girls here's how we do it first
off we're facing against the same type
of ghost that was in the horror film The
Conjuring to side note So based on that
we should have been a little bit better
prepared private schools in general much
smaller so they can oversee everything
that's going on and in order to take on
this thing more effectively there's two
things that rean did wrong that ruined
everything from the get-go one since the
client is coming to us they should have
either helped us get in or could have
set up a meaning that we could have had
access to because this is just
ridiculous and two Reagan here's the
boss man he didn't need to go in for
most of it if I was him I would have
planned better seriously I would have
just leted mob go in first he could
blend in better and scan the area for
signs of ghost ghosts usually haunt
places for these reasons unfinished
business where tragic events happen
positive emotions negative emotions
strong emotions because of this stuff I
would prepared a list of Errors most
likely to be haunted based on these
factors and gone down the list most
likely first in order to get through it
quickly but if we're getting paid by the
hour then I would just flip the list
then we take a super long time and then
we get paid more because I'm bored and I
need the money plus cheating Japanese
school girls out of the lunch money is
going to be super fun and look once we
find the location of the ghost all we
got to do is sneak in from the area
closest to the haunting spot and uh
hello looking around at all girl school
as a grown man is risky as hell from
outside the stadium don't you see that
there's a fence in the background we
could have simply snuck in over there
way easier and we could have done this
at night unlik mob we're not some
overpowered hero destined for greatness
or horrible tragic ending in order to
beat the spirit and as a good first step
for any ghost encounter why didn't he
look at where this all started ghosts in
general thrive in closed off areas that
don't get as much air or life in such as
house that never open their windows or
doors that are always closed and I can
tell that this gym Hall has a few
Windows high up with a steel roof above
it and because of it it's likely that
the inside would trap heat very easily
especially in summer and the high
Windows not being accessible in general
means the gym would have had a harder
time letting out built up heat that
basically means this place was an energy
producing Factory from the start and
whatever ghost was in there was super
powerful because of this I would have
used my very impressive and simplifi
step ghost ass kicking plan one approach
the site cautiously and show respect for
the poal spirit because we don't want to
piss it off more duh and then quietly
open all the doors and windows to let
out any negative energy because this
place stinks and there's bad juju in
here we got to let it out two get some
sea salt magic a little sprinkle
sprinkle of rock out along doorways to
absorb any negative energy left and then
deploy rock crystals strategically
around the building to absorb even more
negative energy these are just rocks
that are capable of undergoing a
chemical reaction and change the state
of the air around it when they react
with oxygen then three whip out a little
bit of herbal enchantment and also all
firmly yet very calmly instructing the
ghost to exit the area without using the
word please the meage say please they
know that you are their [__] pissed off
the Ghost Attacks mob but finds out he's
too powerful and MOB easily defeats it
thinking he saved the school about to
die the sneaky ghost reads his mind and
makes him question if ghost hunting
really makes him happy cuz like everyone
in his life is using him including the
boss he loves Reagan yeah then mob gets
really pissed off at this and then kills
him but hey it's too late you're now at
38% until mob explosion [__] then he
starts to overthink what the ghost set
but he doesn't want to let Reagan down
and quit and because of this he's going
to go through all sorts of crazy [__] in
order to save his life now feeling worse
than before he decides to join an after
school club desperate to find some
happiness before it's too late and then
he signs up for this telepathy Club but
finds out they've been taken down by a
group with the most dangerous guns in
the world these guns the six-pack stud
Club they have co- rented out this room
but mob doesn't realize their muscles
might be the key to saving his life they
tell mob is down and tell him that being
jacked will solve all of his problems
remembering his high school Crush zumobi
he signs up and thinks getting jacked
will finally help him and boy that's a
big mistake he works out regularly with
the Chads but he can keep up and soon
passes out waking up back in school he
gets sad that he's so weak without his
powers and now feels even worse 40%
until mob explosion and he doesn't want
to die so he rushes home to figure out
his next move but runs into someone
strange running into a lady who sells
him happiness cult yeah this lady
wearing a strange masks tells him that
she can tell he's unhappy in life and
asks him to join her totally not a cold
group but Mom doesn't trust strangers
unless she can help him solve his
popularity problems gullible she says
she can so he trusts her immediately and
follows her right into a trap wow this
girl pulled a shady move revealing
herself as basically a mentalist pseudo
psychic who excels at reading people if
he was more self-aware he could have
realized that she wasn't gifted and was
just looking at the signs he was giving
off by the bajillions look according to
experts mentalists in general have
knowledge in these areas memorization
and calculation body language and
reading suggestion and hypnosis and
using all this mumbo jumbo and tricks
you should be able to tell if we're down
about life it carries in our bodies and
reflects how we subconsciously present
ourselves to the world it's noted that
when we're walking down the street we
had tight shoulders a very obvious sign
that is usually caused by stress and
anxiety which is caused by the body's
fight ORF flight response in order to
better help us confront or survive an
incoming threat even when the threat is
all in our head and also puberty related
hormone struggles are common for someone
our age which means The Mentalist had
such an easy time reading us and
probably knew that we even had girl
problems it would have been that hard to
guess it means the mob here fell for the
easiest trick of the book due to his
vulnerability heading in they meet their
leader of the cult Mr dimple mob thinks
everyone here wants to be popular too
pushing him on stage with these other
recruits one of them is a girl from his
class matado the leader tells them they
need to unlock their mind to become
happy but right now it's locked and this
happy mask will solve all of their
problems realizing she's screwed mats
reveals she is actually undercover for
the school newspaper and is about to
expose him for brainwashing these people
but didle tells her she can't leave
until she laughs and then they force her
and mobbed but unhappy masks turning
matado into into a smiling zombie but it
doesn't work out Bob shocking everyone
here and Mr dimble gets angry and
challenges mob to a staring contest the
first person to smile while drinking
milk loses and MOB completes against
dimple's Top members stressing him out
even more and now he's at 58% until mob
explosion and look mob barely wins the
first match and doesn't laugh forcing
diple to join in but he suddenly
realizes this milk has been spiked and
he starts laughing and losing the match
and sucking in one more thing in life
and now he's at 74% until mob explosion
dimple hypnotizes his followers to start
laughing mob realized this cult leader
must have psychic powers and he tells
everyone he can't smile because he isn't
happppy but Mr dimple says he'll never
find love without smiling pissing mob
off even more gosh he's now a 92% until
mob explosion oh no and now he's angry
and MOB refuses to smile so dimple
orders his minions to attack mob right
now and that was his biggest mistake
100% mob loses control of his emotions
and destroys everything here and blacks
out whoa the next day suddenly mob wakes
up but he can tell that something is
really really wrong 0% until mob
explosion and then he sees a strange
spirit in his room 20% until mob
explosion realizing against the ghost
from cult dimple he survived but is now
too weak to do anything and convince his
mob that he'll help him find happiness
if they can Team Up tricking this kid
into the worst mistakes of his life
later at school the bad kid Tanga has a
problem with another school he asks
mob's Club the six-pack studs to help
him take them out but they refuse
forcing him to hatch an evil plan
involving mob a little later mob gets a
love letter in his locker with
instructions to meet at another location
since no no one loves him mob thinks
it's weird and dimble thinks the letter
is fake but mob doesn't listen to him
and he goes to check it out anyways
showing up he gets kidnapped by this
enemy school for showing up to their
gang territory but suddenly his after
school club the six-pack stud show up
since he missed his workout practice
they followed him here the Enemy School
tells these Chads they're about to get
their ass kicked for showing up here
forcing the six-pack studs to take them
out just as Tango planned mob says he's
fine not reveiling that he's starting to
feel something really serious 28% until
mob explosion but fortunately the muscle
group easily kicks all of these kids
asses using their bulging muscles until
one evil kid shows up the one who's
going to cause mob to break down T
six-pack stud Club tells this kid that
they don't want to fight him but he
doesn't give enough and kicks all of
their asses without muscles using his
powers shocking mob at how evil he is
45% until mob explosion T senses mob's
powers and dares him to fight but mob
tells him harming people is against his
training which pisses this guy off and
he attacks mob 47% until mob explosion
but barely even scratches him mob
doesn't want to live a life relying on
his powers T thinking he's a God and
shouldn't be just like regular humans
starts beating mob even more but he
doesn't move an inch dimple tells T to
piss off and tries to stop him but gets
obliterated right away in front of mob
oh boy now we're at 50% until mob
explosion T lunges at him blasting
through buildings demanding he show his
powers and he fires these knives at mob
deflecting and bouncing him back right
at theu baling him mob starts to realize
that ter is secretly scared to live a
life without powers and that's why he's
overcompensating they're basically the
same deep down shocking T he chokes mob
begging him to use his powers 72% until
mob explosion 75% until mob explosion
making mob quickly choke to death 79 80
he punches him softly but turu wants
more 82% about to die 89 he punches him
again 95% finally passing out TR gets
scared at what he's just done and begs
mob to wake up thinking he's dead he
leaves but that's when mob wakes up
blasting to back finally using his
powers and makes this guy happy until he
notices something strange mob is now
unconscious the building suddenly breaks
apart dragging through with him into the
sky in Terror he begs mob to forgive him
but mob can't hear him drowning in
sadness crashing everything down
critically injuring to after mob wakes
up feeling different true seeing his
true power up Riley apologizes for being
a dick and MOB forgives him making true
now question his own life while the
six-pack stud Club cheers for Mob and
after he tries to look for Dio but he
can't find him and goes home feeling
empty without his friend Richi tries to
reconnect with his brother more and
apologizes for harming him with his
powers when he was younger and richo
tells him it's all not revealing that
he's heard from people about what mob
just did and is getting even more
jealous of his powers frustrated Ritu
ends up going for a walk when he gets
approached by this rich guy mistaking
him for Mob he tells him he heard about
what he did to those gang members at
school and tells ritsu that he runs a
lab where kids with weak psychic powers
try to amplify their powers including
himself so he offers him a job thinking
he's mob to help him make his power
stronger heading to the facility he gets
put through a ton of tests but thinks
that nothing's working and confesses to
the rich guy that he actually has no
powers cuz he's not mob and realizing
that his powers deep down have already
been activated while rumors of tur's ass
kicking have now put a target a mob's
back Ru returns home but runs into
dimble who has survived lying that he is
mob's Mentor he offers to team up with
ritsu but doesn't tell him he's trying
to use him revealing what Ritu doesn't
know that he has Just Awaken his powers
because there's no way he would be able
to see him shocking him at all of this
dible offers to help him if Ritu lends
him his body excited Ritu agrees and
gets his body taken over while dimpo
realizes that he's too weak to possess
anyone Ritu thinks his powers must have
always been within him but thanks to the
rich guy his powers have now awakened
but then he quickly figures out that his
personality is changing and he's getting
more power hungry beating up students
they get in his way and he soon bumps
into T dimple warns him to back away
slowly but he doesn't listen and
challenges Tru to a fight Tru warns
ritsu that he used to be like him but
using his powers won't make him happy Ru
tells him to shut his pie hole and gets
put in his place disappointed he tells
dimple he wants to become more powerful
heading back to the lab he reveals to
the rich guy and the other kids about
his recent Powers the next day in class
rzu gets told that trouble is waiting
outside school rival has come to
challenge the one who defeated T and
become the new champion of the school
block Ru goes out and they mistake him
for Mob but rzu easily kicks this guy's
ass causing all the toughest schools to
come for him quickly surrounding him rzu
still says he's the one who beat up too
and starts beating up the kids one by
one not realizing he's being watched by
somebody evil he makes some bad guy
speech now about how he's a God and blah
blah blah and then meanwhile TR watches
from the distance and alerts mob to come
showing up mob is shocked and tells him
to stop being evil but rutu prepares to
go against his own brother and Shake
gets a little too real forcing dimble to
leave rsu's body but now too late he's
already learned about all his powers and
MOB can tell something is bothering his
younger brother but congratulates him on
his powers pissing him off even more
because he wants to know why is Mob
being so nice he reveals due to mob's
unstable Powers he's been scared of him
all these years and was jealous but now
he could finally be free of his brother
mob thinks he's being a little bit silly
and apologizes to all the bad guys on
behalf of his brother because he's like
like my brother's a little embarrassing
right now which Super embarrasses Ritu a
mob says he can't get rid of their
romance cuz they can't suddenly this
stranger jumps down in front of
everybody slamming Ritu with precision
and skill and announces to everyone that
he's come for the most powerful in here
Ritu confusing these two they try to
stop him but get their asses brutally
kicked and suddenly mob is put into a
high state of stress 57% until mob
explosion mob tries to save Ritu but
gets knocked back showing everyone how
powerful this psychic villain is but mob
gets back up now pissed and the two do
get out the enemy creates a telekinetic
Helix punch beating him senseless while
everyone watches sending mob into a
spiral 99% until mob explosion oh [__]
Ritu rushes to stop the fight but mob's
mind finally breaks unleashing a new
power he goes berserk and destroys the
entire area and everyone finally
realizes how powerful mob really is at
his last ropes the bad guy plays dirty
and sprays mob to sleep quickly
kidnapping ritsu not realizing that he
just kidnapped the wrong person waking
up later TR saves mob and tells him who
kidnapped his brother because he's been
tracking them down for years an
organization known as claw made up of a
bunch of crazy psychics that want to
destroy the world they have 100 members
facilities all around the globe and
they've tried to turn humans into
psychics but so far only claw has
succeeded and have turned young kids
into soldiers they're weaker than
natural psychics but their numbers can
easily destroy them and before he got
kidnapped Ritu was visiting one of the
these factories Dio reveals that he's
still alive to M and gets back on his
team before guiding them to where Ritu
got his powers rushing there they notice
everyone's unconscious except the rich
owner guy but he tells them he doesn't
know anything about what's going on and
this whole time he thought Ritu was mob
they suspect this Factory must have
awakened his powers knowing what's at
stake these three plan their next move
TR wants to join since he's been looking
for claw this whole time anyways and
suddenly a team busts in it's Claus
henchman ready to kick ass and they get
beat up in 2 seconds defeated they
confess where their evil headquarters is
and this henchmen tells them what they
should expect to face when they get
there the night they get there and they
Scout around looking for trouble and
that's when one of the henchmen breaks
free from his cuffs giving him time to
activate his psychic powers and throws a
tree of these two he throws TR back
exposing himself but mob brutally
crushes him for good without raising any
enemy alarms heading back to the claw
entrance they use air whips to knock
these guards out rushing in dimple also
manages to possess one of them which is
easier to do when you're in shock and
quickly takes over the area forcing
these two bad guys to tell him where
Ritu is about to split up another
midlevel boss stops and charges in but
mob easily confronts him and sends him
flying back and causes more attention
and alarms okay while this Mission might
seem impossible from the get-go there
was actually a way easier way to get
through this without getting discovered
as quickly as they did R game without
thinking was dumb as hell because the
claw organization is a terrorist
organization hellbent on overthrowing
the world this alone would make it a
tall order for any business to achieve
and means that is safe to assume that
this base would have been guarded like a
mofo since ter mentioned that he'd be
looking for these bad guys for a he
could have told us that the outer area
would have likely been patrolled by
these horrifying psychics known as scars
and one of the strongest commands within
this company usually led by the most
powerful psychic there known as the
division leader even if we were pressed
for time trying to save Ritu I would
have first tried looking for other
psychic members to help us out on this
crazy Mission and then the off chance
that we couldn't I could have at a bare
minimum relied on to's charm this guy's
one charismatic guy all right I would
have had him try to convince some people
at school and have them come along
however I would have instructed him to
lie to the kids by telling them we'll
pay them to help us explore an
interactive escape room in this facility
without telling them what it really is
obviously entering with a bigger group
consisting of mostly humans would at the
very least helped us use them as Shields
of meat as well we could hide our powers
a little better from the enemy while
sneaking in because psychics consense
other psychics and their powers when
nearby but by hiding behind tons of
normies means we could have hit our
presence for a bit longer and then use
these kids as perfect distractions
allowing us to get further in without
encountering much resistance heading in
they split up to find Ritu but quickly
run into a new breed of Awakened
psychics and they're now about to make
their life into a living hell matell
here tells dimple what this facility is
really up to they kidnap weak psychics
and torture them as pain awakens their
true Powers dimble knows he can't beat
him and tries to run but gets the [__]
kicked out of him he can't hold on for
much longer but spots this guy's
weakness each time this guy's pets
attack they quickly rush back to defend
him which must mean without them this
guy's weak as hell Thinking Fast dimple
tries to outsmart him in combat but
instead gets outsmarted himself and is
now captured mean meanwhile Tru tries to
overpower the far powerered Mama putting
up a force field he quickly figures out
he can attack him if his force field is
up and he will soon pass out from the
heat around him if he doesn't put his
force field down thinking fast true
fires his own force field right at Mama
trapping him in all of his fire and heat
together causing him to burn alive
instantly thinking he's one this other
psychic surprises him from behind and
knocks him out meanwhile mob is looking
for his brother when he runs into some
creepy dolls controlled by Puppeteer
Master mukai mob easily defeats them but
finds out he just ped ped off mukai's
trainer the real bad guy this woman
named sui analyzing her she has built up
enough chiong energy around her body and
can Channel all that power through her
fist or knees she launches at mob and
continuously attacks his way mob
realizes he can't do anything if he
doesn't have an opening so he starts
crying instead forcing Sushi to stop the
fight and ask what's up he tells her
that he doesn't want hurt a woman cuz
his master Reagan told him so Sushi
calls him an [__] but a gentleman and
convinces him to put up a fair fight
agreeing mob does put up a fair fight
making Suchi realize it was never a fair
fight to begin with and even this other
Rando guy's ass gets absolutely
demolished pushing through the facility
he finally spots Ritu pass out on the
floor seeing him injured he starts to
feel himself losing it even faster 92%
until mob explosion and suddenly this m
guy shows up and starts viciously
attacking him 98 99 and doesn't stop
there until I [__] 100% mob explodes and
Fries this guy instantly just as this
kid Suzuki shows up the most powerful
psychic of all he reveals all of this
was a trap designed to make mob lose his
[__] and now they have captured all of
them they now dump all of them into this
room Des to turn off their powers making
them helpless all the while while a
special guest tracks mob's location
nearby mob tells T that Ru can help them
get out cuz unlike him he's not useless
without his powers making Ru feel bad
for being so mean to his brother all
these years and then he makes up with
mob someone suddenly enters their cage
it's Reagan Reagan secretly tells them
how he basically snuck into this
facility and made everyone think he was
the big mysterious claw boss through
sheer confidence and tells mob that
since he's been missing work he followed
him here leading everyone out including
the grunts of the claw organization
turning this corner they finally run
into the real bad guys leader ishiguro
and the team they know Reagan isn't the
real mysterious boss because the real
boss isn't supposed to show up here for
another two days Reagan tells the
minions he's made friends with to leave
before they get hurt ishiguro asks who
he is but Reagan totally bullshits them
saying he's the greatest psychic in the
country and pisses off the bad guys and
they show off their powers trapping them
freaking rean out that there are more
psychics like mob out there but he keeps
his cool mob tries to attack the boss
but they discover that she controls
gravity easily and knocks mob down
Reagan runs up and anti psychic drop
kicks her has payback for harming his
student and tells mob that he didn't
know how much mob was being pushed to
his limit all this time and scolds
ishiguro entertain for causing him
stress Franken is angry and schools the
bad guys and tells him that they should
have let the kids leave while he fights
them and whips out his totally fake 5
Yen hypnosis coin approaching the bad
guys they don't sense any psychic powers
coming from him and get confused as he
performs his signature hypnosis punch
and that was his biggest mistake they
realize he's bluffing and try to attack
mob quickly defends everyone as Reagan
quickly realizes his plan backfired and
he tells the kidss to run while he
handles them but mob quickly sees all of
his friends getting attacked and getting
their ass kicked which causes him to
stress out real fast 88% until mob
explosion begs them all to not fight and
run but REO think mob is the only one
who can save them 91% mob watches
everybody loves getting hurt and now he
can feel that his explosion will be more
powerful than it's ever been before 94%
yells to run seeing mob about to lose it
99% he goes to slap him telling him to
chill out and teaches him a new life
lesson he doesn't always have to fight
and handle the world's problems but
that's when Reagan gets sliced down by
this bad guy oh wa everything went tits
up real fast here didn't it but there
was a way that Reagan could have
deceived ISU Guru enough for Mob to more
easily take him out if I was him I would
have spent time chatting him up a little
bit longer I mean come on you just bsed
your way in there couldn't you chat for
a little bit longer because if he could
have this would have helped us Peak into
his character to see if he had any flaws
in this bad guy belief system that we
could have used to exploit and basically
shatter his confidence one way through
conversation we could have done this
would have been by seeing if he
expressed any doubts or hesitations or
contradictions in his statements that
would have told us if he was not
confident in his actions such as talking
about his pursuit of power or the
consequences of using his powers if this
line of conversation hit a nerve with
him by making him act defensive for
example this could have told us that he
had uncertainties about his own path we
could have delayed the time enough that
mob could have used this to take out
ishi Guru and we could have ended this
day without getting our back sliced all
through just pure conversation mob is
shocked and this triggers everything
100% mob explosion mob tries not to
freak out but suddenly Reagan gets up
still alive and is as confident as ever
shocking everybody including me this
monster attacks him he tells mob to help
but realizes he's now powerful as balls
and thinks that these psychics must be
fake while everyone else wonders if
Reagan was pretending not to have powers
this entire time because he easily wipes
the floor with these baddies and Reagan
thinks he's on a roll today Baby Mob
still in shock watches from behind and
wonders why his amazing Master never
showed his powers before not realizing
that his energy during his freak out
accidentally got directed towards Reagan
1,000% now making him the most
overpowered character here it's glorious
seeing the team get defeated ishiguro
goes completely apeshit on him slamming
him to the floor thinking he's finally
won but rean gets back up again and
gives him a taster making him finally
realize that mob must have temporarily
given him his powers with no plan B the
bad guy members try to convince Reagan
why world domination is the most logical
move but he tells them they rely too
much on their powers and basically need
to get out into the world more and they
really just want to escape from society
because they're scared brutally crushing
all of their World Views super quickly
ishiguro tells him that he's destined
for greatness but suddenly gets knocked
out by Suzuki shocking everyone this kid
reveals that he isn't a low-level minion
but actually works for the big claw
organization bosses and came back here
to recruit the bad guys to join him back
at headquarters but now thinks everyone
is too weak and says goodbye to everyone
and says that he'll see them all again
real soon and he disappears now finally
dimple breaks free and says he's now
absorbed all the ghosts in the vase that
he was trapped in and now is all his old
powers back but he will use them for
good now cuz he likes being part of this
team and he has no friends the rest of
the bad guys realize I that they were
the weak ones all along and give up
their evilness and the next day mob and
his bro become best friends again and
realize their differences are what made
them unique and MOB learns to enjoy life
more trying out new things even if he
isn't good at it and does the same
things he did before but this time with
a more positive outlook about himself in
life and re and despite losing his
powers can still see dimple interesting
all the while R and the team all team up
to go part-time on cases while T ends up
going to Rich guys lab to help him train
more psychics preparing for the day when
the claw organization finally returns
but what do you guys thing about the
video let us know what you like about it
and what you didn't like about it don't
forget to like subscribe and leave a
comment down below and as always don't
forget to check out our how toe playlist